رسميا الضوء الاخضر من اداره الغذاء
والدواء الامريكيه من اجل البدء في اجراء
اول تجربه اكلينيكيه على دماغ الانسان
في شركه نيورالينك لصاحبها ايلون ماسك
وزفه الشركه الخبر في تغريده على حسابها
في تويتر معربه عن حماستها لاطلاق اول
تجربه لزراعه شريحه الكترونيه في دماغ
بشري شركه نيورالينك التي تاسست عام 2016
تسعى الى زرع تلك الشريحه في ادمغه البشر
لاهداف طبيه كمعالجه بعض حالات العمى او
الشلل فضلا عن امراض عصبيه اخرى هناك ايضا
استخدامات اخرى لهذه
الشريحه العام الماضي 2022 تحقيقا اتحاديا
في مزاعم بانتهاكات محتمله لحقوق الحيوان
وصل شكاوى من موظفين بتسريع تجارب على
الحيوانات وهذا تسبب في نفوق الكثير منها
دون داعم بحسب ما افادت في حينه
[موسيقى]